welcome to this video playing John none
again dokie yeah he's some playing a
little bit more often recently and also
had his comeback in tournament chess in
the world seniors okay I'm playing this
somewhat down line but i think it is it
has some summer on some ideas that are
not so easy to meet so i'm going to be
curious what is playing let's see it's a
little bit of a different thing there
should be six what I'm what I wanted to
say this is a little bit different than
the normal exchange variation should be
six was very uncommon okay
maybe you can take with Android
maybe 95 94 for the things like that
yeah I thought that this should be quite
nice for Wired actually yeah but maybe
it's not you can take with the bishop
play 97 and but then I can take you five
okay we'll see what happens ok so can
move the bishop or take the night Bishop
d3 will take place is six and I can
probably have to take now block this
Roxy Wallin is a slight hope that I
might can then maybe can do something
against the sea porn yeah that's an
interesting point now I can just take
and then rook c1 Roxy form this is just
equal I am I still pressing a little bit
them yeah
should f form of the should be too i can
just do that actually why not 97 f five
maybe 9075 should therefore I have
Bishop f4 is probably right and
attacking this yes you will take that's
clear and now look c1 which look
actually this one I guess yeah this
should be still a little something for
me unless he's got some some tactical
ideas against the center I mean I don't
know technical is the wrong word but I
mean something something concrete
happening quickly see five psi should
stop this that's a good idea trying to
block the porn from advancing and then
possibly look to see five Roxy for ya
this is an unavoidable in the long run
it's a strengthening and now Bishop a6
as an additional idea yeah okay I'm just
going to drop them here the bishop is
safe yeah Usher basics but he can go to
I know he gets a 95 I should have gone
to c3 problem
okay so that wasn't so ideal should have
come to g3 not to d2 okay so see able to
yes i know i know that you I knew that
you're going to do that but I hope it's
not not that that a bigger problem 93
King III is no problem takes pawn texts
also okay can also take with the bishop
by the way is this better even while
giving is this giving him some tactics
with d3 and stuff other than that this
is a good news okay
and the King now I wanted I didn't want
to do that initially but it doesn't look
so bad the king I can always go back to
f2 or I do you wanna know whatever it's
nothing nothing terrible and the bishop
is not exactly a bad piece on your form
yeah i was thinking if five but maybe
ninety four then yes rabbits is still
good for white and it's still good for
white 94 you can take d to take before
but i have king me three at the answers
as a good end game check okay so going
here
I'm going to see three should might see
for hooking one
okay let's improve here I'm a little bit
down on time
let's let's still plain improving maybe
a bishop fif was good i think i should
have played before the five-time warning
no it's no it's not as good
I think I should have played this Bishop
five earlier but ok take ya Bishop c6
the ship c6
yeah cheated and take him want to see
doing now I can King d2 is not a good
idea ok let's and keep the spawn and it
might be enough to draw track
fortunately now I'm threatening to take
it you will get this ok ha ha just a
dead draw yeah maybe I could could do
something here with the opposite colored
bishop still but I'm not sure ahi I'm a
simple simple shine this would keep two
cons at least not sure I'm ruining their
net F pawn the F porn and the potential
a or b peso should probably win but I'm
curious I mean I around here I let the
biggest part of my advantage slip
definitely around here I'm in excellent
shape and probably should win
somehow but it's not I wasn't so great
maybe I really have to do it do this the
reason why I think that white is clearly
better is well to bishops pawing
weaknesses and more weaknesses even and
mean I'm threatening Bishop a 6cm I am I
just which switched on the comp which is
on 1.7 that it should be excellent comp
gives this as the best defense which is
really ugly something like that will
will win the porn him Kim yeah it was a
very nice position but around here
computer just wants to take the porn I
assembly refuse to look at that well it
seems to be totally okay jack yeah I
wonder about this Bishop f5 move here h4
is strong winds actually okay I don't
know why yeah no it'sit's all all very
close to a win according to the engine
now can look look forever here so it was
kind of a lost have a point okay thanks
for watching